okay so welcome everyone uh thank you
for being here i hope you can at least
see part of my face because i'm really
short and i wasn't expecting everything
to be covering me
so well
today i will be talking about the data
apis which is a consortium that's
working on the standardization of
n-dimensional arrays and data frames
so let's dive into that
first of all i want to talk a little bit
about the current python data ecosystem
so basically as you may know or maybe
you'll be working on this on some part
of this ecosystem we have this main four
like branches that we could say
uh the first one is data science where
we basically just talk about how to
manipulate and do data analysis
uh we have deep learning where we want
to train models and like develop them
and also deploy them
we have the computation side that is all
of you all that do numeric problems do
applications i want to tackle really
hard problems
we also have visualization that are well
all
those interactive graphs reports and all
the things that we are now seeing
so
[Music]
i want to talk a little bit about the
history of how we managed to be here and
how we have the current ecosystem that
we have
so for those that don't have the dates
clear uh python was born in 1991
so it was just a programming language uh
it wasn't designed for numerical
computing
and you know like no one thought about
you know like that we were going to be
this big
after all
um then in 1995 we had the first library
that had arrays and that they let you
manage and
do computations and do scientific
computing
but and thanks to this library numeric
we have the current like typings in
python for indexing because that wasn't
on the python like on the original
python language
uh on 2003 we get a new library that's
called numerate
the ddi was to have a more flexible data
structure that you could do like faster
computations in larger arrays because
that was a lacking point for numeric it
was like really really slow when you
started to do big problems
um but then you know like we had that
fight during those years because then a
lot of people were using numeric and
other ones were using lumaree and they
weren't compatible at all so
the problem arose you know like
how do i manage to send my code if it is
not compatible with the other tool that
my client or my colleagues need so
numpy
was born as a solution for that so they
basically what they did was unify both
numeric and numerate as a single package
and they just fixed that fragmentation
that was at the time
and then really far in 2008
we saw the first version of pandas
that was basically a solution for the
quantitative analysis for toddler data
that we have nowadays
so
[Music]
this is where we are now
we are now having and facing the same
problems that
uh we were seeing in the earliest 2000s
and it's basically that we have so many
arrays and so many data frames libraries
that are not interoperable they are not
like they don't talk the same language
if you start working on your project or
your library that's on
i don't know tensorflow then you cannot
change easily to python and that's a
really huge overhead
and that's something that we want to
tackle and want to change we want
all of these guys to be able to talk up
to each other and for end users and also
downstream libraries to you know like be
able to manage and use all the like
like really like the great tools that we
are working on right now
so
that's how the consortium was uh was
starting to flow
so and well in this little diagram i
have uh that like in the previous slide
i was showing you all the base of the
arrays and data frames
that we have right now but we have so
much more than that
because we also have a lot of downstream
libraries that are using those
libraries to create more functionality
and then on top of that we have more
libraries that are just doing like more
user-friendly apis or more direct
solutions for certain
problems so in this example i'm just
showing you
all the libraries that we currently have
for
managing images
and as you can see we have one for numpy
another one for kupai another one for
dusk another one for jacks and all of
them are different and they offer
different like
functionalities functions methods and
then on top of that we have all the
python packages that maybe you are
developing or that maybe your client is
depending on so
what we want to do is just to
break this and everything
be able to talk about each other and it
is a really
long shot and it is a really difficult
problem because there's a lot of people
involved
so
the main two objectives of the
consortium right now are to develop an
array specification and a data frame
specification uh during the first year
because we've been working now for a
little longer than one year but i'm
presenting you right now or fine like at
what point we were on january of this of
this year
and basically what we want is that we
wanted to define an interchange protocol
for arrays meaning that i can change
from numpy to whatever other library you
may want and also have the same in data
frames
and additionally in the part of the
array
part like portion have that like a
version one api specification
so then you will have the functions and
um methods uh constants that will help
you like with the current
um
like function like these standard
functions to call
like to give them a name
but um basically these are the two parts
that we've been working on and i want to
like mention that we are not working
like we have a part of the team that's
dedicated on the array side of things
and another part of the team that's
working on the data frame because both
of them are really different
so the first year progress for the
consortium um well we started to work
on august of 2020 well that was the
public announcement of the consortium
and that was where the meeting started
in those meetings we have a lot of um
like people that are involved in any pro
it all the projects so we have
maintainers from numpy kubai
um
x-ray
in the data frame side we also have all
the
all the major ones
and
like i take this space also to note that
if you are developing an array or a data
frame
library we like and you want to be
involved then you just have to send us a
message and then we can arrange that
um then we had the first
version of the api on 11 of 2020
which was pretty fast you may think
and that is because the array side of
things are really developed like
you you've seen that we have a lot of
history with arrays and it was fairly
easy because all the arrays have like
the same structure and like more or less
the same functions they may not work the
same and they may have like small
variations in what they are like
returning and what are the arguments
that they have but like the majority of
the functions were the same so that
makes like that like don't make the work
really like easy if you want to say easy
so
um on february of 2021 uh nep 47
was
published and it was the first
discussion about the adoption of the api
in numpy and this was really a milestone
and it is super important because a lot
of libraries
of a race were trying to match whatever
numpy was doing
so
this is like really useful because then
people are you know like they if they
follow numpy and we get numpy to get
their api
uh implemented then everyone will follow
easily so
that was a huge milestone
uh then
on august of 2021 we have
the
request for comments for the data frames
so basically i'm going to speak a little
bit more in detail about this in a
minute but
uh it was the announcement for the
interchange protocol for data frames and
also the adoption in bikes and qdf
of the array side of things
and finally in
september of 2021
we had the experimental module in numpy
and kupai which was uh
like it was a fairly easy transition
as you can see because a lot of things
were already implemented they just
needed to
match a little bit of like they had to
do like really little changes to their
like actual apis
um and more than that is that we also
are working on tools that will help
on just like create these apis but also
to maintain them
and to like for you to users uh also
downstream libraries to know where all
the libraries are at so
the first thing that we have is the api
comparison so basically we developed a
tool that is able to go and compare all
the apis in multiple array and data
frame libraries and just match what's
what is different
it could be the name of the function it
could be an argument of the function
uh the return types um all that you
think that will be different we we were
measuring that with that tool
we also developed a python record api
which basically what that was doing was
to register the consumer usage on a
target python module so for instance i
will get geopandas and then i will run
all the tests for that module and then
i will see
in which parts they are using the arrays
for data frames and which functions in
particular they are using and that is
helping us a lot because then we are
knowing what people are using like
there's a lot of functions that maybe
people are using that heavily
and then we can understand why that's
happening and if they are important to
the final goal or not
so that's on that part and finally we
have the
one of the most important tools there is
the test suite
which is the one that measures the
specification compliance of a target
library with the standard api so the
idea is to if you have your array or
data library then you will be able to
run the tests against the
api standard and then you will know how
compliant your tool is
so let's dive into a little bit of the
array part of things
so the actual state is that we already
have a defined object which is an array
and we have 11 data type support
we have four numerical constants
and we are
using an interchange protocol that
enables
uh to change the device so it will not
matter if you are using a gpu a tpu or a
cpu
and
the biggest portion of the work is on
the functions so basically we right now
we have more than 125 functions that
enable you to manipulate to do
comparison to do element-wise functions
statistics and linear algebra and those
are like all standard and the idea is
for all the libraries to get to this
point where they have a
a place in their maybe it could be the
module like in a submodule or something
or a new namespace where they can create
this um like this state where they will
be compliant
so if you want to dive and really
see what's
like under the array specification i
invite you to go to the data apis.org
and go to the our api like it is
relative you type our api
and um like data apps then it will be
the first link that you see on google
and if you have like we have all the
specifications for all the functions
we're defining all the documentation in
numpy install docs so we also have
um the repository that has all the like
function handles so then you will be
able just to fill whatever you need on
that
and also in our github account we have
the issue tracker if you are interested
in seeing
why we're making some decisions uh to
see all the resources and also if you
have any comment or any
um like question or think that we could
get better on then
we would like to hear it on our issue
tracker in their api
uh the future work for their api
involves uh four major parts which are
adoption extension compliance and
outreach
so the first one is adoption we now have
a like preliminary version of the array
specification and now we want to
accelerate that
adoption the idea is to increase the
libraries that are complying with this
and this will not just enable the like
base libraries of the arrays to be
compliant but also to all the tools that
are using those libraries to be
interoperable among each other which
will be really cool if you have
uh i don't know like for instance a
plotting library and then you could like
receive multiple types of arrays on
there and then it will not matter if
it's an umpi array or a desk array and
everything will work
the second part is the compliance so we
are working really hard for the
completion of the library independent
test suite that's
right now on beta but we hope that next
year that will be um like complete and
all the libraries could um just run
their
in library independent test suite and we
can also show it on our webpage like you
know those things for
web development where you say like oh
this tool is compliant with this web
browser the idea is that we want to have
that for every library of a race
and then we have the extension
this array api is more like a living
organism it is not static it is
constantly evolving and it's constantly
adding new functionality modifying some
things
so basically we what we want to do as
well this following year is to add these
new functions in the api
like
complex number support fft support or
even a deep learning module
and finally we want well to do more
outreach because a lot of people are not
aware of this work that that's been
happening like for these past like two
years so what we're doing right now is
doing a lot of community outreach to
involve more libraries and more projects
to know that this is happening and if
that you are a maintainer of any library
and you want to like be involved it is
really easy
so that's enough for a race and now i'm
going to talk a little bit about the
interchange protocol for data frames
and the first question that i have is
what is a data frame
so that
question was like the first one
that you may need for standardizing the
data frames and when you start to think
about it
it is really hard to define
what is a data frame because it depends
on the library you're working on so for
instance ibis
just works data frames as
tables while
pandas
has a more complex
structure with columns series
indexing even multi-indexing so it is
really hard like you know like if we
were starting to think about how can i
interoperate between those two libraries
it is really hard because the concept of
what is a data frame changes really like
greatly so
um the first thing that we started to do
was to create the minimal representation
of data frames
so the idea is to create like the
minimum things that i need to have a
data frame that will be like useful
and also the important thing is that
this will allow a serial copy data
interchange
among all the data frame libraries
so
um
the characteristics of this minimal data
frame are basically that the data frame
can be chunked so
it a column may not be continuous in
memory that happens like as in dusk
um
that the column is a 1d array with a
data type and has missing data support
and finally that we have unique column
names so
we don't have two columns that have the
same name
and uh this is a work in progress
because
data frames are like fairly new there's
like pandas released the version one
like
i think it's not a year since they
launched um their their first version
like the 1.0
and uh it is like really flexible
and so we are like we we are having a
lot of discussions on how to manage this
um data frame standardization
just because in the base all of the
definitions for a data frame are so
different and are so complex because we
are at the end trading with tabular data
that we don't know how
how it is we don't know if it has
strings we don't know if it has numbers
we don't know what type of numbers they
have so it is really tricky and that's
just like the surface of it because then
we also have all the indexing and
everything
starts to be really complex so
on the same like if you want to
read a little more about data frame
uh like the different power of things uh
we have the data frame webpage
and we also have a repository
specifically for data frames so if you
have any requests for comment or you
know like any
things that you want to see in there or
see all the like discussions that are
happening then you can go directly to
the github page
so the next steps for
our
consolation work
involves
developing and
see an expression for the
array api standard which basically will
include complexity types more linear
algebra and more apis so we are
currently working a lot of complexity
types so then we can add an fft module
and more things that are associated with
that
and that will help a lot with
downstream libraries that have that use
like really heavily
so then we can also start to measure
how
like how easy is to
start having this array part of things
um working and we can start to see that
interchange among libraries and also
like with downstream memories and
everything
on the data frame part of
things we want this year to have at the
end a developer focused api
so we want to
define like go more than defining data
interchange protocol and once that's
done then we can move on to how we
develop that api with the like minimal
things that all the data frame libraries
are using
um basically the consortium just wants
long-term stability and we want to break
that fragmentation that we have
currently on our python data ecosystem
and
yeah basically i think this like this is
really important because it touches a
lot of things that are in the base of a
lot of things that are like built-in
python and specific on scientific python
so it is uh really
useful
so thank you very much uh here is my
email and my twitter handle if you have
any questions i will be really
happy to answer you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we have a few questions on
slido
um number one how does apache arrow fit
into this specification
uh so pacharo is part of the
construction right now we have a couple
of containers on the meetings
um they are working really hard to see
how they can fit in but a lot of the
decisions that have been like written on
the like documentation for the
um
for the array specification are taking
into account all those libraries that
are not like
built like numpy
right
another question from slido has this
performance impact
some decisions will have some
performance impact yeah because yeah
like a lot of things like of decisions
of base for a lot of array libraries
specifically and also data frame
libraries
uh they did it because of performance
but not all of the libraries have the
infrastructure to match those things so
we will be like
losing a little bit of performance just
to
make room for the interoperability
and third question apart from a common
standard and representation is there any
effort to ensure that the new api
standard will also allow for
computational improvements as well
we have to see that
we we hope to like this year especially
on the right side of things
uh there are a little bit more mature uh
we hope to start seeing more
implementations done and then we will be
able to measure the impact on downstream
libraries and other like end users on
how they're using and how performant it
is so that's something that we we will
have to see how it evolves
okay another question just came in
why do you have a hard distinction
between arrays and data frames aren't
data frames just two-dimensional arrays
with unique column names
so
um
it depends on the like what that's why
the
question about what is a data frame is
so broad um because basically we have so
many like um definitions of what a data
frame is some say that it is just an sql
like like table
others say it is a lot of arrays like
one-dimensional arrays with a color name
and then we have uh like in reality it
is more than that it is a little bit
more complex at that um because we
normally have an index and then people
will be doing things weird things with
that index and in the case of pandas
we'll be doing uh weird things with
multi index so that's that's another
level of complexity and that's why data
frames are a little bit trickier than a
race
okay
so no more questions on slido anybody
from the audience would like to ask a
question
i think there are some cases when you
still want your index and column names
uh to be a part of your logic but your
data doesn't necessarily mean that your
columns are just 1d arrays but maybe 2d
arrays even
is there a plan support for this
those are the hard questions that we're
trying to solve right now because
there's a lot of
um like end users that are different
like that are not like a 1d array with a
unique color name so that's what's
making it really hard but we are
definitely working into a solution that
will fit everyone
which is really hard because they like
all the needs in data frames are really
broad so
yeah
anybody
else then i think we're done
please a round of applause for stephanie
[Music]